how do you know someone is serious about
working in this business
that they will Implement advice that is
given to them
I can't tell you how many times how many
words I've probably expended Into The
Ether with people who were looking for
validation in that moment as opposed to
something practical that they could put
into practice or that they want to fight
with you about the advice that you give
them
well Quentin Tarantino doesn't do this
and I'm like well you know the reason
why he's Quentin Tarantino is because
he's the exception to the rule
when I was in film school all I ever
heard about was how Robert Rodriguez
made his movie for well he made that
movie for three hundred thousand dollars
and I said the music Budget on El
Mariachi had to have been more than
three hundred thousand dollars when it
was released
I said there's a point between where you
start something and then someone comes
in with a bunch of money to finish this
idea you had
like The Blair Witch Project you know
the the myth is that it's a bunch of
guys that were just
they did this thing and it turned into a
big hit just by accident well you know
new line got involved and somebody said
well maybe you should show more of this
lost footage than just doing it as a
straight up Talking Heads documentary
about something
and sure enough you know the the thing
that scares the hell out of everybody is
that last shot where somebody's standing
in the corner and you know something
awful's happened or is just about to
happen and it scares your pants off
that was because of an exec which is the
other reason you should listen to notes
once in a while and stop thinking I'm an
auteur when you haven't made anything
yet
what does it mean to quote look like you
want to work
look like you want to work uh for me
uh it's an old thing that I kind of got
when I was a kid I used to read
everything I could about the people who
were really great successes and like Lou
Wasserman who ran Universal for a long
time
um Lou Wasserman had his whole thing
about you know
direct dress British act Yiddish
and if you work there you you're at MCA
you were going to wear a black suit and
a skinny tie and you were going to look
good I've done shows where my whole
staff back when I could suggest
something like that
I would say you know please wear a shirt
with a collar to work like please like
please don't come into a band with a
band t-shirt on because I want us to
feel like we're professionals doing a
professional thing and not the thing
that we're doing because we're not
making movies or things that we really
feel like are what we're called to
because it just to me it's disheartening
to see people that look like they live
out of a glove box
coming into the office every morning to
work like you gotta just respect your
peers respect your work act like an
adult professional
and that's from guys like Lou Wasserman
and Paul fig who I love to pieces that
man is wonderful and always the best
dressed guy in the room
advice to those who want to start at the
top
go soak your head in a bucket there's no
starting at the top if you want to join
the Army as a general
let me know how that works out when you
go down to the recruiting office I'll
join if you'll put me in charge of 200
000 people doing ground operation
somewhere it's like that's not how life
works it doesn't work that way in the
film or television business
we'd like to be recognized for our work
we'd like to be famous we'd like to be
loaded we'd like to know what it feels
like to make you know four million
dollars a year
but there's a long road
to get there and I just had a
conversation with a good friend about
that today who was
talking about she said I don't really
know what to do with my life and she
says I'm you know I'm your age and
you know everything is sort of worked
out for you didn't say in so many words
it was more like
find something that you know that you
like
find something find a job that's
adjacent to that and do it for a year
and see where that year shows you things
I thought for a while between doing
comic books and ultimately reality
television I'm going to be a
screenwriter and I wrote every day and I
had so many spec scripts that were awful
I was doing my friend Larry Katz I used
to tell me he says just get the mustard
water out it's like when you turn a two
mustard over and it's like you get
nothing but water on your sandwich it's
like so disappointing it's like just get
the mustard water out and then just
worry about where to apply the mustard
you got to get the mustard water out uh
in your career because you'll start in
One Direction and you'll start to see
doors in that same hallway open to you
and say well that's further down the
hallway that's close to the door at the
end with a big star on it where you feel
like you're somebody important
you gotta just work your way down the
hallway and there's lots of doors and
lots of offices and lots of other things
you can do
that are going to give you experiences
that'll drive you to that the more you
know when I started in reality
television I thought well you know I'm
going to get stuck here
you know it's not a matter of being
stuck it's like I've become
arguably like the guy to talk about
story and structure in reality
television I've talked to Sid field
about it in my lifetime I've had
interactions with people who do all
kinds of things Ted Elliott who wrote
the pirates of the Caribbean's movie he
said the most important thing about this
business is understanding how the how
your business works you can't be in a
business that you can't be bothered to
learn how it operates
and that's good advice when you're
getting started too it's like you got to
learn about the business get up in the
morning and you know go through the
Hollywood reporter.com go through
variety see who's making what so you can
be conversational if you run into one of
those people or somebody they're
connected to
I heard you're working on this is a
great conversation starter
or how's it been going with XYZ
what kind of heart does it take to
pursue this business
uh a sturdy one it is oh it's super
important to want to do what you do
but resilience is a huge part of it
and you can't act like people are
actively I hear this conversation like
oh nobody wants to read my script
because the studios only want to do the
things that are safe and it's like yeah
they're like whatever you do don't buy
anything from Jeff
is that there are no meetings where
they're plotting about how to keep you
excluded it's a business
we made a movie like this and it made 60
million dollars we'd like to make some
more mid-range movies like this with a
safe return so right now we're going to
buy movies that are like this it's not
like they're going to look at your thing
and say well this in and of itself does
not have Merit in its crap
it's not how it works they'll read it
they'll go this isn't what we're looking
for right now
like for me
I keep a thing called The Brick which is
every idea I've ever had for a reality
TV show that I was unable to sell at the
time that I created it
put it in a three ring binder come back
to it later and I keep the brick and I
hear oh somebody's looking for a shiny
floor game show that's like this or
something that's in the vein of that and
I can go to the brick and I'll have
something ready
that I can go in and pitch
so
I have multi-general game monthly
generational game shows I've got
takeoffs on things that were already
successful
there was a show that I created last
year about it was basically I really
loved making it I thought that was a
great show I don't know if you've seen
it or if you're familiar with it Nick
Offerman and
Amy Poehler do like a crafting show
where people compete to build these
different craft projects
and I said well what if you cross that
with which is the best phrase
to come to when you're jammed and your
brain doesn't work as it's like it's
like this and this at the same time
so like what if we did making it in
Project Runway and we did a show that
was all about trying to figure out how
to upscale clothing that you find in a
thrift store to make it look
contemporary
and every week you got to dig through
this big pile of clothes and make
something that somebody has to wear and
show off
like that would be fun went out to pitch
it oh well you know we're not really
looking for shows like that
you know I just I would die to sit down
with paper kite the company that did
that and just
run through that show but it just
if it doesn't sell you just print the
copy of your deck and you put it in the
binder and then two years later you'll
hear somebody at a table somewhere
talking about how they wish they had
something like X Y or Z
and then you say well I've got the brick
and you go back to the brick and you
pull it out and you call your agency and
get a meeting and hope for the best and
sometimes on the second or third time
something will go into development and
maybe you'll get lucky
you won't get rich anymore
but you'll get lucky well if if you
enjoy what you do though that's right
without sounding too cliche but I mean
yes money is important in in L.A but
also it's it's that thing where the the
spirit of what we do like this much
validation goes to here
like I've I've got a scripted series the
first time I've ever
um done a scripted an attempt at a
scripted series that's been very well
received I have some producers that I'm
working with on right now and hoping
that we'll be able to go out with it
soon it's based on one of my books
and it's like it's it's a new stretch
it's someplace new to go and just the
validation of having someone say that is
an interesting idea
like it's like the carnival where like
the lights run up to here and back down
you're just like all I gotta do is hit
it hard enough again to get it to the
Bell
you know it'll happen and it won't
happen tomorrow which is the other thing
that I would tell people are just
getting in
this idea that like I'm going to pull
out a spec script I'm going to mail it
to somebody on a Friday that didn't ask
for it and I'm going to hear about it on
Tuesday
I got your thing over the weekend wasted
my weekend reading it but I like it
it doesn't
so much about building relationships
that you have to give yourself time to
build relationships which again young
people they're not
the fact that I'm using the phrase young
people worries me
because old people do it too they get
this idea well I got this great idea and
well I can't get anybody interested in
it what's it about well it's about
Broadway in the 1920s and you're like oh
my like do you not understand why
somebody might not do that right away
like it's it's about this woman her name
was Emma and she was a costume designer
in the 1920s and I'm like
could be real interesting but it's gonna
you know it's going to have to have a
lot of stink put on it for it to be
something anybody wants to do
can I do a multi-million dollar period
piece about a seamstress like tell me
all about it
just learn the business understand what
people want and that it's cyclical every
seven years you get a really great
vampire movie
and that's just how it works because if
one thing becomes successful everybody's
trying to mimic it
so there's going to be this
you know this rash of people buying
obscure amazon.com novels about vampires
to adapt into screenplays
and then it'll be over again and you
won't hear about it again for nine years
because everybody will be so sick of all
these properties that they bought that
they couldn't figure out how to develop
and move forward
give yourself the time
well things have sped up so much so
whether whatever end of the spectrum
age-wise someone is everything's so
instantaneous now right so we all want
this you know and we're it's shoved in
our face every day this person's you
know
that pressure that we all feel that I
and I know that when I started the
dialogue that was always running in my
head is everybody well if you haven't
made it by 30
it's not going to happen like in
Hollywood they love young people because
they only develop young talent because
they want to have a long career that
they can make money off of you
that's why when you when you go to an
agency when you're 65 years old and
you've written your fantasy novel
it's a little hard for someone to say
yes to that because they know that even
if it's successful and they develop you
out you're going to work what 20 more
years
it's a very it's a very tough thing for
older people to break into the industry
you know
it's you don't have to be 25 to have
stars in your eyes
but still I mean it's
not it's not
wanting it is not enough
you just gotta launch yourself into how
things really work
and looking for those little doors which
is another thing Larry talks about a lot
I reference Larry Katz a lot Larry was
an ad that's worked with gorbital not
gorvin Al Gore verbinsky
and lots of other people and he's a
super talented guy teaches at Full Sail
University in Orlando but he talks a lot
about approaching show business like
it's you go to this huge castle and
you're just trying to figure out how am
I going to I'm going to break inside
this castle like it looks like they're
having fun there's fireworks there's
people running around like I want to be
in there
and you're always trying to figure out
how to go through the front door and
what you got to do is watch the side and
figure out where the little hidden doors
are where the gates are where the
windows are and eventually one of those
little doors will open and you can run
into that
you know there are people that get into
this too all crazy different ways like
Chuck that I talked about earlier uh who
does
uh or who did uh movies of the week for
a long time did TV movies he got into
the business uh had a relative that was
able to get him in at the with the
finance department and Civ he didn't
start out as a writer or producer he got
in that little side door and worked his
way forward if you look at Norman Powell
who was a very successful uh producer of
Westerns
he was the same way his father was a
very well-known film star
and he went to his dad and he was like
what what can I do how can I get started
and his dad was able to get him in uh to
directing and he eventually started
directing episodes of westerns and moved
up and did a lot of films and other
things
um it's it's not always a straight path
do you have to really break in can you
be invited
oh a lot of people get invited in
um but it's it's if you sit by the
mailbox and wait for that to show up
it's not great like
you'll get invitations when you've known
people for a long time
like it's like I talked to I talk about
like the Hollywood party thing a lot
is I didn't get invited to anything for
years because nobody knew who I was and
then out of the blue I got invited to
some fundraiser that the creative artist
agency was doing
they didn't rep me I didn't have
anything to do with them I just got
invited
and I showed up and it was this big
thing that Carrie Elvis was putting on
that they were doing a benefit for some
sort of a rainforest initiative
that was going to keep people from
drilling for oil or clearing for oil in
this area where this group of indigenous
folks were living and how are we going
to raise money to stop doing this and I
thought halfway through this we're all
going to be asked to write a check and
I'm like I am making nothing it's this
part of my career
but it was a great night and I met a lot
of people
um I didn't become fast friends with all
of them but I knew some of them and some
of those people have asked me before to
read things that I've written or is
there anything they can do to help me
out
but it took me you know years to get to
the point where I would get invited to
anything
and then later on
um we talk about ali Willis a lot is she
actually credits herself as a
lyric Lyricist uh and Hollywood party
thrower technologist all these other
crazy things she's like a
multi-hyphenate
um but she's proudest of being able to
throw parties because what she does is
she loves connecting people who will
then go off to do other things or
potentially bring her on to do other
stuff
and she had a wonderful career
that all sort of worked through that way
she started out at uh Columbia Records
in New York she used to be as she was an
assistant
who then ended up writing liner notes
who then left the company and tried to
get a recording contract with them did
one album called child star that was not
the best received album ever It's a
Wonderful listen
but it was one of those things where it
was a very personal effort that didn't
just register like popular music would
and she got those opportunities because
people people liked her
so if someone is invited to let's say a
fundraiser or something where they know
like this is worth my while to go I may
or may not be able to contribute how
should one conduct themselves
I would tell you when you go to a party
like that
and there are big names everywhere
they are not there for you to run up and
go my name's Paul and I have this really
great idea for a thing of blah blah blah
or oh I love that movie you made 15
years ago and it's so great whatever you
do don't walk up to someone and go you
saved my life that's everybody's
favorite phrase you saved my life and
you don't even know it
these people get that on the street
all the time you are in a space where
everybody in that space should be safe
for them to interact with
so I like to go to people and say oh I
know you you're a friend of like even if
I know who they are I'll say like I met
John Cryer at a Ralph's once which is
not a big big deal I think he's a great
actor and a neat guy
and I had just been at a play the week
before and I saw him there
um with an actress named Paget Brewster
who is somebody that I also enjoy
and I turned to him and I said oh I know
you I said your pageant's friend I met
you with the at the show at the Steve
Allen theater last week and oh hi I'm
John I was like no I mean I know who you
are I just I just remember you as a
friend of
pageant I said I didn't want to come up
and go oh you're John Cryer I figure you
get that all the time he's like oh yeah
I'm actually going over to hang out with
her right now
so remembering like you said a safe
space so we're not there to pitch their
their their IMDb doesn't really exist
right it doesn't exist it's worry about
making a personal connection that's just
like oh so and so I just you know I'm
taking acting classes with this person
that you studied with in 1970 or I know
like this tangential thing about you
that connects the two of us have a
genuine conversation
circle around meet them at the end of
the night
um and whatever they say
don't don't react badly
to anything someone says there's a
there's an A-list comedy star
who is a with a glowing halo around it
that I met at the Christmas party years
ago
and the interaction we had I said
oh hyped so and so on and I said I've
really liked you in such and so and he
says oh are you in the business and I
said yes I said I work in reality
television and he said oh and then got
real quiet and then he punched me on the
shoulder and said someday for you buddy
and I was like dude I've just I've done
I have more completed projects than you
do like in the number of hours I had
probably done
10 times the amount of time he spent on
screen in the movie
someday for you buddy was really
offensive like it was it was not a blow
off it was a oh you're not really doing
what I do what yeah
you can't internalize that the fact I'm
remembering this story 10 years later
makes me feel awful
and I will never tell anybody who it was
sure
but it's just that whole thing where
it's just like if you have a sour
interaction with somebody that's on you
whatever happened however they reacted
to you whether they were right or wrong
it's a thing that happened in that
moment and you can't you are not at the
point where you can afford to have
grudges when you're starting out you're
just going to be like oh well that's a
funny story that I'll tell in 10 years
when I've cooled off
and there's is there a hazing is there a
toughening up
there can be but mostly with people you
don't want to work with
um most people I know who are very
serious and adult and professional are
super accommodating and very nice I have
a friend of mine who is an audio mixer
who when he was doing the final pass at
Bridesmaids
said you know why don't you come down to
you know come down to Technicolor and
we'll go out and grab some lunch and
when we came back Paul fig was there to
sit in on the mix
and I introduced myself to him I said
always I'm a friend of Marx I said you
know I said I wish I would have worn a
better suit I said I feel like herb
tarlik from WKRP in Cincinnati I said
that is such a beautiful suit and I'm
here in this
crummy Blazer
you know I said you just look like a
million bucks oh thank you
and we don't interact that often but
when we do it's always very pleasant and
he's a nice guy and it turned out later
on that he was a friend of my friend Ali
that I talk about all the time so one
more thing we have in common my book
came out I sent a box of them over to
his office if anybody you know might
enjoy this
I don't expect him to read it I just
it's that thing where you know I'm just
trying to figure out how to keep in
touch with people
which I'm so sorry tangent
send people cards anybody you've met
that you feel in Affinity with
send them a card when some new project
comes out just to let them know that you
still think about them I worked with
Sean Hayes from Will and Grace one time
on a show called Hollywood Game Night
and I still whenever I see he's got
something new especially if it's
something independent or small
hey I just saw Lazy Susan which was a
very strange movie that he's in it's
very funny so hey I just saw Lazy Susan
I didn't even know that this was
something that you had worked on it just
popped up on my Netflix and I loved it
and just drop the mail and that way
hopefully
the next time I bump into him which five
years from now 10 years from now
I'll still be able to say oh I sent you
a card after Lazy Susan and he'll go oh
I remember he's the guy with the weird
jackets and the crazy glasses they used
to work on Hollywood Game Night
you might see him in the produce section
at Ralph's it could happen
I don't have I don't have the best time
with pretty seconds at Rouse I mistook a
very popular uh actor named George
weiner who has worked forever who's been
a lot of Mel Brooks films I met him in
the men's room at Musa and Frank once
and my brain shorted out and I said
excuse me
I said aren't you Ron Liebman who's
another actor
and he said no not Ron Liebman but he's
a friend of mine and I thought he was
pulling my leg
and I said well then I won't say
anything about where's papa and this is
the really weird part
George weiner wasn't in where's papa it
was Ron Liebman he was just wearing
glasses similar to the ones that George
was wearing at Muslim Frank these sort
of oversized Dior style glasses
years later I ran into him at Ralph's
and I said this is a funny story but I
owe you an apology and he said no you
don't he says I've told that story for
years oh wow about this guy that kept
telling me I was that thought I was
lying to him when I told him I wasn't
Ron Liebman and I'm like oh good now we
have a funny story
so you made an impression in the men's
room I made an impression yeah probably
not a great one but at least a funny one